on the way out of crimea but very much
still in charge
russia's land sea and air forces are
heading back to their bases
after two weeks of exercises along the
border with ukraine and in the black sea
it was a mobilization big enough to
worry nato with at least a hundred
thousand russian soldiers
estimated to have been involved but
russia is keeping up the pressure on its
neighbour
by closing the kirch strait to the
ukrainian navy
this links the black sea to the sea of
azov and ukraine's eastern ports
russia's main motive is to demonstrate
that it controls crimea
because russia has recognized crimea as
part of russia
for the very reason to control this
equatory around around the peninsula
and closing down the this trade it
demonstrates who is the master
in this part of the black sea and in the
azov sea
the bridge over the strait was built by
russia in the years after its 2014
occupation of crimea
it creates a permanent link to the
russian mainland
there's a treaty between russia and
ukraine agreeing equal access to the
azov
sea but russia says it can close the
strait for military exercises
and these will last until the end of
october there's not much
ukraine can do unless it wants to take
on
russia's navy bernard smith al jazeera
crimea